from a singing sensation all grown up to
a mesmerizing sand artist and even a
surprise celebrity cameo Monday's
America's Got Talent the champions was
stacked with impressive performances and
heartwarming moments last time you were
on America's Got Talent you were 10
years old how old are you no I'm 18 now
that's Jackie Evancho the little girl
with the big voice we met in 2010 during
season 5 since then she's become a
platinum-selling artist but a big goal
remains a second shot at that number one
spot on a GT
[Music]
being back on America's Got Talent
was just such a surreal feeling when I
walked onto that stage everybody looked
and they're like that's her because I
look so different from when I was ten
hopefully but yeah it was so nice to be
back where it all began well what I
really want people to know about me now
is that I'm not just this weird
ten-year-old girl who has an adult voice
I'm also an artist and I have a big
passion for what I do my face was not
the same as it was when I was 10 so I
think for them they were kind of like oh
she really is a woman now
[Music]
thirty-three-year-old sand artists
Ksenia simonova one Ukraine's Got Talent
in 2009 for ability to tell stories
through sand art completely captivated
the judges
[Music]
but it was host Terry Crews who had the
biggest response by the ability to move
people away you did today
[Applause]
the greatest talent competition in the
world man this is it with AGG you never
really know what can happen for example
you never know who might just show up in
the middle of an act who are you
thinking of
[Applause]
[Music]